[Music]
there's a black professor at emerson
college who's just been promoted to
become an interim dean
she says that whites and blacks can't
really have meaningful relationships
should not have meaningful relationships
and i thought to help me work through
this i would like to invite on a black
woman happens to be a professor herself
with whom i do have a wonderful
relationship to see if we can disprove
this theory i'm talking of course about
carol swain former tenured professor of
princeton and vanderbilt has lots of
fancy degrees has lots of fancy awards
from academic institutions the author of
among other books black eye for america
how critical race theory is burning down
the house carol thank you for coming on
it's my pleasure are we allowed to have
a relationship anymore no that's over
because the interim dean said so isn't
that so sad all i can say in the truest
southern sense
bless her heart
i i would say i can't believe she said
this but i can believe it and i'm not
even surprised when i read these things
anymore
uh you know they they seem to occur day
by day and week by week some other
divisive outrageous false
racial ideology i mean we've just seen
justice for that uh racial attack on
jesse smallette his attacker was brought
to justice happens to be himself
complete racial hoax so i guess my my
first question for you is uh carol
how is critical race theory burning down
the house
well first of all the house is america
and if you look at what was happening
last summer
after george floyd's death i think we
had 50 straight days of some city you
know in turmoil vandalism fires
deaths
it is turned apart the country because
it is pitting whites against blacks and
that professor at
emerson college she was married to a
white man
she divorced him because of his race and
i would say that crt
is so divisive that it's reached the
point you know that it's breaking up
marriages and this racial visceral
hatred that she has
had she been a white person
she would have lost her job by now right
uh because it would have been it would
have risen to the level
that um even a tenant professor would
not be able to get away with that if
they were white and so what i feel about
america when i look at all of these uh
racial incidents that are occurring
and i look at how they handle the it if
the perpetrator is black
versus a white perpetrator and the whole
idea that people make the argument that
black people cannot be guilty of racism
that white people cannot be victims of
hate crimes
it is ludicrous and we cannot have true
equality in america until we hold
everyone to the same standards of
conduct and behavior and moral decency
well it seems like this professor's
actions undermine her claim and you see
this in a lot of the left's racial
theory she is espousing this idea that
black people and especially black women
are
exceptionally oppressed and white people
and especially white men are the
oppressors and so she
says this view she says white people and
black people can't have relationships
she leaves her husband because of his
race
and she gets away with it whereas as you
say if a white person had done that
obviously their life would be ruined so
doesn't the reaction to what she has
said and done
suggests that perhaps she is of the the
privileged sex or race and that maybe
the situation is kind of the opposite of
what she's saying that it is
of course it's the opposite there's no
truth to it but
the whole idea that we would give her a
free pass
that she would be able to make those
outrageous dangerous damaging statements
be in a position to be a role model you
know for hundreds if not thousands of
students
and uh
it would just you know we treat black
people as if that kind of behavior and
attitude is somehow normal behavior it
is not normal behavior it's obscene it
should be condemned and it grows out of
this critical race theory because it's
all about dividing people on the color
of race on the color that because of the
color of their skin but white says the
oppressors and
and racial ethnic minorities as the
victims but it is rooted to critical
theory which takes many forms there are
other critical theories and so they
divide homosexuals from heterosexuals
males from females rich from poor uh
blacks versus white these are all
critical theories they're rooted in
marxism and you know post-modernism
and all kinds of other things and it is
dangerous and destructive for our
society
in my book black guy for america
which happened to be co-authored with a
young
white guy who started off as a research
assistant and because this young white
guy was such a good scholar
i uh promoted him the co-author
uh we look at what crt is where it came
from
how it manifests itself in our society
why it's un-american why it runs counter
to our constitution
uh and our civil rights laws and then we
have two chapters on how to fight back
against it and so we see crt as a danger
in fact i have argued that it is the
civil rights issue of our day you know
we're told that and it seems that a lot
of people know
that crt began
in harvard law school
with theorists such as kimberly crenshaw
and
and after that things get a little
confusing because what the left says is
crt remained in harvard law school and
didn't really go anywhere else and it's
not being taught in lower schools and
it's not in our corporations and then of
course out of the other side of their
mouths they're saying and actually crt
is in all of these places and that's a
good thing and but but it's a little
hard to pin down i remember i think it
was martin j
the sympathetic historian of the
frankfurt school and critical theorists
generally said that critical theory is
less its own discipline than it is a
gadfly on other disciplines that it's
sort of an analytical framework that
begins to infect all of all of the other
so so how do how do you go from harvard
law school to crt
ostensibly everywhere else
you mentioned kimberly crenshaw and so
i'm going to give credit to derek bale i
don't know if you read in school faces
at the bottom of the well and his uh
fictional account space traders uh i
think kimberly was a student of his and
she brought us intersectionality
but um
the crt is clearly rooted in the
uh critical theories you know related to
um you know the cultural marxists
and it uh just morphed uh and it has
infected every institution
and discipline within the academy and i
guess it would have been okay if it had
stayed at the universities
but it got into the departments of
education and when the obama
administration you know came to power
it was not long by 2012 that was when
you saw it really impacting k-12
education uh and uh the criminal justice
system with arguments about restorative
justice
and um
and so you know people are becoming more
aware of it because of george floyd's
death and the money that's been poured
into it from corporations trying to buy
peace and virtue signaling money has
given it you know
more strength than it should have
but it is something that we should all
fight against it's very harmful to
racial ethnic minorities as well as
to uh
you know caucasians it's harmful to our
american society and we should not uh
give people that um
divide us in the way crt theorists do a
free pass and we should not give them
access to our children
so now how do you stop it because there
are governors such as ron desantis who
are going in using the power of the
state and saying look the state has
obviously a role in education a lot of
these are public schools and so we're
going to say no you're not going to
teach this stuff to our kids then you
have some people maybe the more
libertarian minded who say no we don't
want to kick any books out of school we
just want to teach all sort of points of
view and we'll open the curriculum up to
everyone and we don't really want to use
state power so in terms of the nuts and
bolts of how you get this poison out of
our lower school you know middle school
high school even elementary school right
how do you do that well i can tell you
that it is in k through 12
and you may have seen some of the
research i know that you have a uh
yo little boy how old is he now like
eight or nine months ago yeah he's uh
a little over 10 months now
okay well according to uh some of these
race theorists by six months a baby can
be racist and so little white babies and
little jewish babies or whatever they
can be racist
and so sesame street and nickelodeon and
all of those children's programs are
trying to
indoctrinate uh these children
and they're trying to make them see
color because naturally kids just you
know they see their friends they see
people around them they see who they
like but we're trying to consciously
teach them to see color and to guilt out
white people to make them feel ashamed
especially if they come from a normal
family a two-parent family uh if they've
been successful then that's undeserved
well you know that's white privilege
and
i have been around long enough to know
that
you know white privilege
a lot of it does black privilege that's
hispanic privilege in most cases it
means that your parents made good
decisions and you have benefited from it
and um
it is
in the k-12 there are books that they
may not be quoting derek bell and
kremlin kimberly crenshaw or richard
delgado but they're taking their ideas
and they're distilling it down to
children and it creates i would say a
hostile learning environment shaming
bullying of children and teachers
and it's just unacceptable and it's
un-american to allow that we should all
fight back against it
you know i have no evidence that my son
is racist but i i'm open to the
possibility because i know that my son
is sexist because he loves mommy and he
has absolutely no interest in daddy so i
don't know maybe he's racist who knows
these kids according to the left they're
so so evil these days guess how the
research is it's my understanding that's
part of the research to determine that
these babies are racist is that they
prefer some faces better than
others
and i'm thinking that if i'm a baby i'm
going to prefer the faces that are
changing my diapers and feeding me
hugging me those are going to be the
people that i prefer and so that makes
me racist as a baby then you know so be
it that means that in every ethnicity
there's a whole bunch of racist babies
uh if they're being raised by their
biological parents that took care of
them and show them love that's right i
know my baby i suppose he is
anti-italian because my wife is not
italian i am he doesn't have any
interest in me so it's it's as they say
in the sopranos it's anti-italian
discrimination and really i mean we're
kind of joking about it but you are
seeing the left go more and more into
not just putting this stuff in the minds
of grad students or college students or
high school or middle but it's going
down to elementary it's going down to
preschool and
at the same time you're seeing this
coupled with a move from the left to get
more and more kids into preschool
earlier on and to keep them in college
later on i mean you see the growth of
education too well michael
we're focused on crt and you know that's
what we're talking about today but
just as dangerous is a critical career
theory critical gender theory because
they are sexualizing kids that are in
kindergarten and you know they're
confusing them
telling little boys that they may not be
little girls and they could i've heard
stories of children after they get this
sex education being terrified that
they're going to turn into the opposite
sex
and so we're focused on one thing but
there are other critical theories that
are just as dangerous they don't belong
uh in k-12 education
and we have to root it all out
it's a very good point because while we
focus on critical race theory
frankly the critical sex and the gender
theory is is probably more dangerous i
mean the
sexual distinction in human beings is
much more fundamental than any kind of
racial differences and uh so so what is
the solution to this though because in
the old days you would say
look we know that there are boys we know
that there are girls we know that boys
and girls naturally want to do certain
things together and people might have
aberrant desires and and understandings
but look there's true there's false
there's natural law there's certain
things we're supposed to do and so get
in line with what's uh
with the t loss get in line with the
natural order and the theology of the
body if you wanted to use a technical
term today we're not allowed to say any
of that we're not allowed to say that
there's any uh better sexual behavior
than any other sexual behavior we're not
allowed to say there's any substantial
difference between men and women and
we're not we're barely allowed to say
that there's such a thing as objective
truth so how do you go back
well i could i tell you that again like
the obama administration i don't want to
say it was the root of all evil because
he will proceed at the obama
administration
but um
the
activism
of
the lgbt community where it pertains to
our children uh where you have
transgenders and uh you know lesbians
and homosexuals talking about their
sexual behavior to that to the children
you know and just really pushing the
activism
uh that some people warned about they
said it would happen and of course they
said oh no it wouldn't happen and i
don't know if you followed the fact that
the biden administration
is trying to change the
the policy at the department of
department of education so that they no
longer track
sexual activity between adults and
children like these teachers you know
that assault their students
engaged in pedophilia they don't want to
track those uh numbers and it's just um
and i don't see that getting a lot of
attention it's not getting the immediate
attention that it should uh you know we
should be up in arms about it because it
does lay the groundwork for normalizing
pedophilia we know a lot of it takes
place uh in in the classroom with
teachers because we see all these
teachers you know that are having sex
with their students the whole idea that
an administration would argue
uh that we don't need to collect that
data and make it public it's absurd
you know i actually had not heard about
that story but i'm not surprised some
years ago conservatives said as we
always do we said this is a slippery
slope and if you permit certain sexual
ideologies the next thing you know the
left is going to try to normalize
pedophilia and they told us that was
completely insane and it was never going
to happen and you just had a professor
who came under fire recently for using
the term minor attracted person he said
he wanted to d he or she i don't really
know because his gender was sort of
confused so i'll use him as the uh a
single gender-neutral pronoun but he
said that we need to de-stigmatize
pedophile pedophilia because they're
born that way because they have these
these desires and the desires are static
their whole lives and his view was that
they can't change them in any way and so
if you're going to begin with those
premises then what's the flaw in that
let me tell you his research is not very
original because um
back i would say 20 years ago they were
using the concept some people
inter-generational
intimacy
and that was a euphemism you know for
sex between adults and children and so
in academia you know you get paid for
coming up with ideas and usually the
more bizarre the greater the the reward
and so he just gave it a new spin i
think it was professor at old dominion
university and i believe he lost his job
but um
he was clearly uh
confused sexually by just looking at him
and
you know
i don't know
but he was certainly laying the
groundwork for
relationships between adults and
children and they have openly made the
argument at times that it benefits the
children
uh we have a sick society around us and
i think that um
if we are going to restore anything that
resembles you know our judeo-christian
roots as americans we're going to have
to confront some of this stuff and they
may call us names they will call us
names because they do always call us
names but it is worth it if you speak up
then someone else will speak up and
before you know it you have
moms for liberty and moms for america
and you have all these groups of people
that were not activists but they are
they're fighting hard for their children
but if we're going to transform the the
culture in this way and transform the
whole conversation and get rid of some
of these crazy ideas then it seems to me
we have to be able to say that some
some things are better than other things
some desires are better than other
desires that we actually can kind of
shape to at least some degree shape our
desires you you know you practice the
virtues then it gets a little easier you
start practicing vices it gets a little
harder to stop it's kind of like a drug
addiction right the more drugs you do
the harder it is to stop doing it
but then what you're going to be told is
hey you can't legislate morality stop
forcing your your religious views on me
who's to determine what's right and
wrong and you get this breakdown and
we're told that in a totally secular
society total total separation of church
and state you're not allowed to have
those kinds of opinions in the public
square wait a minute you know they make
that argument but they they actively
proselytize they actively indoctrinate
our children they actively recruit and
so we need to have enough courage to
call it out for what it is
and it doesn't matter what they say look
at what they do
that's a good point yeah you say i'm
going to proselytize at least as much as
you are guys which means basically you
could bring back the spanish inquisition
and it would probably be not not even
close to what they're doing uh carol
i've got to let you go but where where
can people find the book i think you
what you had two books out last year i
do let me tell you this michael black
guy for america had critical race
theories burning down the house is my
first best seller it was seth published
it sold over 20 000 copies you know with
me promoting it and then i had a book
released in september now this book is
not as popular so i need you to help me
popularize it
it's a counter cultural living what
jesus has to say about
life marriage race and ethnicity
gender identities and
materialism and i use my life and my
mistakes and i've had a messy life i'm
in my 60s michael when you reach my age
you know you've been through a lot of
stuff
um and i can talk about how not to do
life but jesus has a better way
and it's a short book i mean it's um
shorter than black eye for america and
both of those books are well under 200
pages because i know people are busy
they don't have time to sit down with a
long book
uh and so i won't i'm writing for the
american people and i'm writing to be
read and i'm writing to help uh
transform lives and i believe that we
will win this victory
and i would tell people to be encouraged
uh what you see with your eyes is not
the true reality there's more of us than
there are of them i love it i'm very
pro-short book carol you know some of my
favorite books ever written i think are
the most profound are really short
because they say most books should be
essays most essays should never be
written and people go on and on and on
but you just distill it give them
exactly what they need so the two books
can't believe you would write i've
written two books ever and one of them
didn't even have words you write two
books in a year uh black eye for america
how critical race theory is burning down
the house and counter-cultural living
what jesus has to say about life
marriage race gender and materialism
from one of the greats carol swain carol
thank you for being here
thank you my pleasure and merry
christmas mary you're not allowed to say
that carol you can't save everybody
merry christmas to you as well
[Music]